the cybersecurity directive is a latest
component in Europe strive for digital
supremacy for the first time
coordination is being sought for
essential services such as air traffic
control health and financial markets but
to lead the world first things first
reading any chinks in your armor that
could leave your system vulnerable to
cyber attacks if there is a hacker out
there that tries to hack your hospital
data that these data are really
protected in a way that there is no
danger to be displayed elsewhere than
where it is allowed companies would have
to have robust enough systems to ward
off online threats and report any
serious incidents to a national
authority but beyond the sector's a
country could deem is crucial to protect
the likes of Google Microsoft and social
media sites would also fall into the
ambit these internet giants and network
specialists are just asked to inform
public authorities about structure
protects about information about cyber
attacks day together the days of the
Internet's world world West could soon
be coming to an end